And we're going to excuse Mayor Gray and Ben
Reeves, our city manager, because they are in New York
right now attending to some city business to help us with some things that we're
working on. We're going to move into the Pledge of Allegiance,
and I will lead you in that. Please join me for the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of
America and to the republic for which it stands. I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America, and to the republic for which it stands,
one nation under God, indivisible, with liberty
and justice for all.
Okay, so this afternoon's meeting is going
to be short and sweet. It was something that we needed to call a special
meeting for because of some timelines and deadlines.
So we will be looking at a resolution of
Eagle Mountain City, Utah, protesting The Red Cedar Corporation annexation
petition filed with the Town of Cedar Fort on July 27th,
2026. And I'll invite Marcus to
present the item. Yes, so we became aware of this, I believe yesterday,
that the petition for annexation was filed under
state code. Prior to even filing the petition,
the petitioner should have sent a notice of intent to file a petition with
us. Because we are an affected entity, and that is one
of the procedural problems with their petition.
So we drafted a protest letter because this overlaps
with our annexation policy plan expansion area, and and we
have some interest in potentially annexing a portion of that
proposed annexation into Eagle Mountain City.
Additionally, we've had contact with.
the representatives of several of the landowners that are proposed to
be annexed into Cedar Fort, and they do not desire to be annexed into Cedar
Fort and are very troubled by this petition.
So we are filing as an affected entity. We have standing
to file a protest, and that's what this would be, a resolution to do
that. Thank you. Just— and I'd like to recognize
that Mayor Gray and Ben Reeves are
both online, but because they're remote, I'll continue
to conduct the meeting unless the mayor tells me otherwise. Um,
does council have any questions about the item that is at hand?
This is Craig. I have no questions. Okay.
Council Member Hewish, do you have any questions?
I think, uh, this, this is just a procedural step
in a protest. What, what is the next step after the protest is filed?
Yeah, so we'll file the protest with the Utah County Clerk,
after which the Boundary Commission would have to set a date
for a public hearing, and we would have the opportunity to present at that hearing.
And then they would make a decision on how to recommend,
you know, what Cedar Fort does. My reading of the
laws is not actually binding on the town of Cedar Fort, but it
would certainly bear a lot of persuasive weight. We would have, if they went
forth with the annexation, then we would have to look at other legal recourse if
they chose not to follow the Boundary Commission's recommendation.
Okay. Councilmember Wood, do you have anything that you'd like to share?
Nope. All right. So with that, if no one else
has any other items— oh, okay. Steve.
Just, uh, Marcus can clarify for me, but it
appears unless Cedar Fort changes their mind,
on September 15th they will still have a public hearing on this. They can't move
forward with the public hearing while there's a pending protest.
Okay, what I read in state code was that they can
have the public hearing, they can deny the application, but they can't approve it.
Yes, I mean, that's a little bit more, I guess,
precise. Yes, they could deny the annexation petition
without waiting for the protest to play out, and that would moot the protest,
but they can't approve it until the protest plays out.
Marcus, maybe I have one question. How is it that they can,
Force a landowner to be part of an annexation application
against their will? That is one of the problems with the
petition. Under state law, you need
to have landowners covering at least 50% of the total
area within the annexation, proposed annexation area, that signed the petition.
And my understanding is that did not occur here, that it was only
the Red Cedar Corporation who was the petitioner. They're the only ones that signed it,
and they own approximately a third of the land area, and none of the other
landowners, most of which are associated with the Holbrooks,
And they none of them signed it. It's my is my understanding,
and so that is one of the procedural
problems is that it's the petition's invalid because it doesn't have the
adequate signatures. That being said, my reading of state law
is if you do meet the requirements and have 50%
of the landowners sign, say the landowner is covering 50% of
the total area, and that covers one third of the total value. If you meet
both those requirements and a couple other minor procedural requirements,
you could force other landowners into an annexation
into a municipality that they don't want to be annexed into. So that is something
that is allowable under state law, but not under these circumstances.
Is the reason that they're being included in this is because their property
lies between the applicant and the city that
they want to annex to? So in this area, there is a,
I guess, a corridor, if you will, of parcels that
are between Cedar Fort and Eagle Mountain and within unincorporated Utah County.
The Red Cedar Corporation parcels are actually just to the north of this corridor.
And all the ones to the south are, again, most of them are
associated with the Holbrook family. And I
can't, I mean, I have ideas, but I don't know what their motives are for
including them. Thank you. Okay, no further questions.
Thank you. Does, does anyone else on council have any more questions or any more
comments from those that are present? All right, so then I'll call for a motion.
Mayor Pro Tempore, I'll make a motion. I move that the
city council adopt a resolution of Eagle Mountain City, Utah,
protesting the Red Cedar Corporation annexation petition filed
with the town of Cedar Fort on July 27th, 2026.
Second. All right, we have a motion from Council Member Wood
and a second from Council Member Wright. Let's begin the vote with me.
Yes. Council Member? Yes.
Council Member Whiting? Yes. Council Member
Wood? Yes. Council Member Hewish?
Yes. Good job, you guys. I had a real hard time because we don't have
our name plaques up.
Thank you all for that. I'll call for a motion to adjourn. You need
to announce that it's been, uh, what the vote was.
Um, the, the vote, uh, was 5 to 0, passes.
Will you entertain a motion, Mayor Pro Tem? I sure will. Motion to adjourn.
Oh, second. We have a motion from Council
Member Wood and a motion, a second from Council Member Wright. All in favor,
please say aye. Aye. Aye. All right, we're adjourned
at 5:23 PM.
Thank you.